in this series I'm going to surprise you
I'm going to strip away all the
complexity and hardcraft and teach you
how to cook amazing food standing on
your head that is amazing incredibly
tender from the kitchen novice to the
buing chef I'm going to give you the
confidence the recipes and the inside of
knowledge to make you a much better cook
slice around wasting
nothing I've been cooking in
professional kitchens for over 25 years
what cheese is in the macaroni now I've
been taught by some of the best chefs in
the world and in turn I've taught some
of the best how much whiskey in there a
little bit now I'm going to show you
some simple and accessible recipes for
fantastic food that you can easily cook
at
home incredible I'll be holding you by
the hand it's getting better and better
and better teaching you everything from
how to cook with chili and spice to
bacon real fast food and my ultimate
feast recipes this is the only cookie
course you'll ever need
Welcome to My ultimate cookery course
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to stay your life on the
frying pan is one of your best friends
it's so versatile in the kitchen
learning to use it with these is a must
and I'm going to show you
how first up my delicious pan fried pork
chops with sweet and sour
Peppers whether it's in the restaurant
or even at home one of my golden rules
for producing fantastic food is love
learning to cook with confidence this
recipe is so straightforward but tastes
absolutely
amazing pan on get that nice and hot you
think of the sort of density of a pork
chop how it needs a little bit of
help Sweet Sound Peppers go brilliantly
well first slice the peppers that's the
flat side of the pepper so stand it up
trying to slice of pepper on the side is
a nightmare there's the Center start off
it's almost like sort of peeling an
orange go all the way around and
down and look that's what you
want now place the pepper down three
finger rule one finger in front two
behind pinky holding it down thumb
holding it nice and flat the flatter the
vegetables the more confident you are
when you slice so don't worry about the
speed just let the knife do the work and
take your
time speed comes the most important
thing is to get your Technique right red
onion now sweet sour Peppers olive oil
in I'm going to sod them which is just
the chef's term for shallow frying on a
high heat for maximum
taste some salt and pepper add a
tablespoon of sugar sugar helps to break
down the peppers quicker but caramelizes
the onions frying them in a frying pan
perfect it's one of the sort of basic
essential tools of any kitchen because
it's so multi-purpose great for saan
tossing great for cooking fish and
meat push away and pull back push away
and pull back that hissing is something
you need to hear constantly because the
minute that's gone your peppers and your
onions start to boil and you really want
them to so it you now start to see it's
glistening in a way that it's starting
to caramelize Sugar's working
eely that's ready pour the red wine
vinegar
in smells incredible it helps to stain
the peppers as well look at the glaze
now you see the
sugar it's worked is Magic turn down the
gas and add a couple of tablespoons of
fresh extra virgin olive oil let them
stew for 2 to 3
minutes now I want to make the peppers
nice and light and sort of sweet
aromatic just roll the Basel almost like
a big cigar
slice baselin and then literally cook it
out for 30 seconds I want them
off
beautiful okay pan back on and now for
the pork chops I want to make sure they
don't curl up in the pan they start
curling up in the pan they're going to
cook unevenly a few simple cuts through
the rine means the chop stays flat and
Cooks
evenly point the knife down flip through
this season the
beautifully nice large shards of pepper
punch that through lightly guaranteed
that seasoning is going to stay there
hot pan Touch of garlic and a touch of
thyme the garlic take a couple of cloves
don't peel it don't chop it just knife
on crush it
olive oil in just starting to smoke top
of the chop in and lay away from
[Music]
you
nice keep that heat in the pan put the
garlic in there early a nice fragrant
bunch of time see how the pork is stayed
nice and flat turn that over look at
that beautiful I want a little bit of th
underneath there start squeezing that
garlic out I want the flavor coming
out butter in thin slices of butter tilt
the pan and
base so I'm sort of speeding up the
cooking process at the same time I'm
keeping the pork chopped really nice and
moist and now look at the color that
butter it's almost like sort of a nut
brown check the color on the other side
useful when they're that thick 3 and 1/2
to 4 minutes each side 30 seconds from
now they're going to be medium so I'm
going to take them out and let let them
rest the secret to perfectly moist pork
chops is letting them rest almost as
long as they cooked in the
pan a nice spoon of these Peppers the
Basel smells incredible keep that garlic
on there be generous with that vinegar
out from the peppers because it really
is
incredible do two things simple like
that pork and peppers and your
confidence is going to shoot through the
roof a stunning pork chop with sweet and
sour
Peppers the frying pan is so simple but
incredibly useful with this one pan you
can make a million different
dishes the more you cook with your
frying pan the more your confidence will
grow here are three of my favorite easy
pan fried
dishes first up pan fried scallops with
crunchy apple
[Music]
salad get a frying pan smoking hot
essential for quick pan
frying add olive
oil then season scallops with salt and
pepper starting at the top put clockwise
into the pan so you know which one to
turn
[Applause]
[Music]
first scallops have firm white sweet
flesh and cook in
[Applause]
[Music]
minutes next salad Lamb's lettuce match
sticks of Apple
[Music]
seasoning lemon zest and
Juice add olive oil then
[Applause]
[Music]
toss turn the sculps when golden going
clockwise around the
[Applause]
pan then squeeze in lemon juice and give
the pan a
shake
finish with lemon
zest ready in under 10 minutes my first
pan fried dish scallops with crunchy
apple
salad my next super simple pan fried
recipe is chicken and chickory and
Masala
[Music]
sauce season the chicken
breast add the hot olive oil skinside
down lay away from you to stop the oil
[Music]
splashing sliced chory this versatile
vegetable can be read all white has a
lovely bitter taste and is great cooked
or
raw crush a clove of garlic and add then
Springs of
thyme when the chicken skin is crisp
turn over along with a
chory for the sauce add Masala a sweet
fortify wine from
sicy then 150 mil of chicken
[Music]
stock to make the sauce wonderfully rich
and glossy add butter and simmer for 10
minutes plate up and spoon over the
sauce cooked and under 20 minutes
chicken and chory in Masala
[Music]
sauce
my final dish cooked in The Versatile
frying pan is seab bream with tomato and
Herb
[Music]
salsa fry fets of seab bream skinside
down in hot olive oil if they buckle up
press gently down for perfect even
cooking then
season sepram has firm white flesh
perfect for pan
frying next the
salsa heat olive oil add half cherry
tomatoes pitted black olives and
[Music]
[Applause]
season after a minute on a low heat add
coriander Basel and
lemon combine and leave to
infuse as a sea bream Cooks it goes
opaque when it's 2/3 from the top turn
over
[Music]
base fry and it's
done SE bream with tomato and Herb salsa
ready in under 15
minutes one pan three simple impressive
and absolutely delicious dishes
beautiful coming up on my ultimate
cookery course along with 100 recipes to
stake your life on I'm going to give you
100 quick cooking tips to make your life
in the kitchen
easier first up how to keep your knife
sharp it's far harder working in the
kitchen with a blunt knife than it is
with a sharp knife the secret behind
keeping a sharp knife sharpen it before
and every time you use it first grip the
steel feel really comfortable about
holding the steel imagine you're holding
a tennis racket or you're playing squash
you've got to be really comfortable with
it now 45° confident grip confident grip
with a knife this is the butt of the
steel really important you keep your
fingers behind there you never grip a
steel with your fingers over that cuz
the knife comes back in you've just lost
a finger always grip behind nice long
strokes so we get the whole of the
blade over steel stroke and we start
from the bottom to the top so there
across there across slow Strokes over
the top of the steel and then come back
underneath then back underneath
it is so dangerous working in the
kitchen with a blunt knife you can cause
so much damage working with a sharp
knife is 10 times quicker more efficient
now that's ready to start
chopping to stop your chopping board
rocking or slipping a great tip is to
Simply wet a kitchen cloth kitchen paper
or tea towel and place it
underneath now you can chop with
confidence my next top tip is get the
most out of your humble veg peeler it's
brilliant for slicing ultra thin ribbons
of veg perfect for Asian dishes great
for making long delicate Palmers and
shavings to top soups and
salads it also makes wonderful chocolate
curls your pepper mill is more versatile
than you might think tighten the top
screw to get finely ground pepper ideal
for Soups and
sauces for general seasoning you want it
medium ground so set the screw in in the
middle and loosen it right off for
coarse pepper perfect for steaks and
fish peeling garlic for one clove simply
bash it with the back of a knife and the
skin comes off
easily for a whole head Crush separate
into a
bowl cover and shake hard for about 10
seconds then simply pick out the peeled
cloves
coming up on my ultimate cookery course
more great cooking tips just hold it
down and put your fingers on there it's
a really nice way of taking off all
those nice fragrant little thme flowers
how to shop for the best ingredients the
Skin's a nice white color and it smells
like a fresh chickeny smell and a
stunning roast chicken recipe to stake
your life
on
[Music]
incredible this is my ultimate cookery
course 100 recipes to stake your life on
I'll be showing you a roast chicken
recipe to die for hold the drum and
slice straight
through but first like any good Chef I'm
always looking to get great ingredients
at the right price my shopping Mantra is
simple first rely on your senses make
sure whatever you're buying it looks
smells and really feels good and if you
get the chance taste it before you buy
it second is to recognize that knowledge
is crucial the more you know about where
your ingredients come from and how
they're produced the better so ask lots
of questions and
learn you're never too old to learn from
experts and when it comes to buying
great birds one person knows what to
look for is award-winning fifth
generation Master butcher Danny lidgate
poultry is a great meat because there's
many different types of birds is worth
tasting the variation of flavors between
different birds to birds is massive
turkeyy is a great lean meat that's
available all year round not just for
Christmas anybody who's worried about
eating fatty Meats it's a really healthy
flavorsome meal game birds people don't
try them often enough once they're shot
they're hung up for a little while for a
few days at least it means the meat's
going to be more tender it all adds its
flavor to the birds you've got a wood
pigeon and a redle partridge both really
good and cook really
quickly when you're buying a chicken
some of the things to look out for is
obviously the smell and when you're
smelling a good quality chicken you can
tell the difference the Skin's a nice
white color and it smells like a fresh
chickeny
smell when you're buying from a good
butcher you'll find you tend to get the
giblets as well which is basically the
neck and other organs this is great for
making gravy once you have cooked it you
can use all the off cuts for other
things stir fries curries past the
dishes save the bones use the bones for
stocks and soups they're really Pack
full of
flavor and remember there are lots of
different breeds of chicken all have
different characteristics and flavors so
shop around and find the ones you love
here are three of my all-time
favorites the label onlay these come
from an old British breed they've got
smaller breast but the meat's
delicious the black leg a fantastic
French variety succulent with bags of
flavor and really meaty
thighs and the pul deess this is the
Rolls-Royce of chickens rich gy and
delicious one for special
occasions I think people should maybe
try and buy Less meat but aim for the
best quality you're only going to get
out what you put in by putting the best
quality into a dish you're going to get
the best
results no matter how seasoned a chef
you are there are always new ingredients
and recipes to get fired up
about so if a tired old recipe is
getting you down spice it up with fresh
ideas and
flavors my next recipe is an old classic
roast chicken but with a simple twist it
takes on a new life and is guaranteed to
impress one of the things I love about
cooking and that keeps me excited after
25 years behind the stove is that
there's always something new to learn
every day new ingredients new techniques
and new
Cuisines start off with the
stuffing it's amazing how exciting a
stuffed roast chicken can be because it
keeps the chicken incredibly moist and
gives a delicious texture inside the
bird going to start off with cured cero
this is a traditional Spanish sausage
and it's garlicky spicy incredibly
meaty that gives a little bit of sort of
richness to the stuffing get that cizo
in start cooking that down and getting
all those oils out little touch of olive
oil in there to get it going right
onions
chopped add the onions to the cizo and
in a matter of seconds they'll change
color as they soak up all the flavor
that lovely spiciness has been stolen
from that sausage now the onions smell
incredible
garlic gar fresh time just hold it down
and put your fingers on there and it's a
really nice way have taken off all those
nice fragrant little time flowers you
can hear it crackling in the
background these are canellini beans
they're waxy very soft and so delicious
but very dense but for stuffing they're
so robust nothing breaks down drain them
off
in they're going to take on all that
juice as well from the szer I'm going to
season them now because they're very
dense so it needs some
help I mean that looks like it's a dish
on its own good enough to eat now I want
to sweeten things up a little bit
Tomatoes half dried in that sweetens
up the
stuffing beautiful the stuffing is ready
look at the color of everything looks
Spanish it looks delicious now stuffing
the chicken I like taking off these
little
knuckles as the chicken Cooks the skin
stretches over the bone you can get a
really nice drum and take off those
little wing tips as well salt
pepper so
important now we go stuffing I'm going
to go right inside the
chicken push it down this really helps
to cook the bird evenly because you're
pushing out all the empty spaces in the
carcass and take a nice large Lemon push
the lemon in pick up the Parson's nose
pull the skin over olive oil on
top salt and
pepper teaspoon of paprika sprinkle it
on and then get your hands and sort of
rub that in see what the paprika is
doing to the chicken putting this like
sweet spicy marinade it's not even
roasted yet but it looks
delicious 400 mil white wine same
quantity of water that helps the chicken
to steam chicken in be generous with the
time
[Music]
sprigs make sure the f is folded tightly
around the roasting tray so the chicken
steams in the oven keeping it moist and
juicy into the
[Music]
oven cook for 1 hour at 180° with a foil
on nice take it out and remove the full
lid then give it another 30 minutes to
crisp up that
[Music]
skin look at
that so important to make sure you take
that tinf fall off with half an hour to
go beautiful Pierce that open squeeze it
in that delicious gravy mix that into
the
tray and sive
that that's a really nice fragrant
lemony spice roasting juices to
finish before we cut up the chicken take
out that amazing
stuffing incredible I'd have that with
chicken over potatoes any day and then
just get your chicken roasting
juices now to cut the chicken
up hold the drum and slice straight
through and there's that wonderful drum
and the thigh through the
wishbone off slice with the point at an
angle so you can see the texture of that
amazing roast chicken just take my
cooking juices just want to give a
really nice sort of lemony
flavor over my chicken there you
go a delicious very Charming stuffed
roast
chicken
in this series I'm going to surprise you
I'm going strip away all the complexity
and hard graft and teach you how to cook
amazing food standing on your head that
is amazing incredibly tender from the
kitchen novice to the buing chef I'm
going to give you the confidence the
recipes and The Insider knowledge to
make you a much better cook slice around
wasting
nothing I've been cooking in
professional kitchens for over 25 years
what cheese is in the macaroni now I've
been taught by some of the best chefs in
the world and in turn I've taught some
of the best how much whiskey in there a
little bit now I'm going to show you
some simple and accessible recipes for
fantastic food that you can easily cook
at
home incredible I'll be holding you by
the hand it's getting better and better
and better teaching you everything from
how to cook with chili and spice to
bacon real fast food and my ultimate
feast recipes this is the only cookery
course you'll ever
need Welcome to My ultimate cookery
course pack with cooking tips
information and 100 recipes to stay your
life on right tonight is all about
keeping it
simple keeping it simple in the kitchen
doesn't mean you can't have amazing food
that not only looks incredible but
tastes fantastic
too my first recipe is so easy it
removes the stress from cooking and is a
pleasure to make chili beef lettuce
wraps cooking should never be a chore
the more you cook the more confident you
become that way you actually start to
enjoy it and that's the key to good
cooking have a bit of fun along the
way this is minced beef and minced pork
the pork needs to sit in there otherwise
the beef is going to dry out it's really
important to season the mince before you
cook
it pan nice and hot Touch of olive oil
mint in breaking up like that really
helps to sort of separate it so we can
fry it off with a lot of color with your
spoon just go
[Music]
through and start breaking that up the
most important thing to remember is mint
is made up of cheap cups brisket belly
short rib so it needs help and frying
off the mins for color is so important
this p pan wasn't hot your mints is just
going to boil there a horrible gray
color on there and there's no flavor on
your mints taste a little
bit tastes delicious it's seasoned
beautifully see how crispy it's going
take it much further than you ever taken
mint before nice and
crispy smells
incredible and draining it is crucial it
keeps the mints nice and crispy and you
get rid of that excess
fat that's
lovely now let's Wipe Out the pan don't
wash it low gas now we're going to add
texture to the mins finally chopped
chili ginger garlic and spring onions
spring onions give the sort of mints a
really nice
freshness cuz it just gives that
crunch nice and thinly now going fry off
the chilies the ginger and the garlic
first Sesame Seed Oil teaspoon only in
garlic chili ginger in FY that off
nicely the sesame seed oil just lifts up
the whole flavor tou brown sugar that
starts to really caramelize the chili
the garlic and the ginger mince
in now my fish sauce that gives it the
saltiness you can see now why it was so
important to get that mint really crispy
because nothing's going soggy it's
staying really crispy
fresh lime that makes the mints
fragrant and then lime juice roll it and
squeeze that in
there incredible I've got the salty i'
got the heat I've got the sweetness now
I've got the acidic as well and then
finally my spring onions in right the
last minute so I've got crunch in there
as well
smells amazing literally cook the mints
now with sort of 30 seconds to
go gas off and take it
out looks incredible smells so
inviting to go with a chili beef I'm
making a simple sweet and spicy dipping
sauce so everyone can dress the crispy
mints to their own
taste dipping sauce little teaspoon of
the brown sugar soy sauce gives it that
nice sort of dark Rich color
sesame seed oil a tablespoon and just
top that up with a
tablespoon of olive oil that stops the
sesame seed all becoming too rich a
teaspoon of fish sauce and then a touch
of chili and leave the seeds in again I
want the heat in that
sauce so impressive and amazing showof
centerpiece lime juice
in in the coriander chop it through once
give that little mix up just check the
seasoning that's lovely nice and rich
now the lettuce I'm going to use baby
gem cuz it's really nice and durable and
sort of quite strong so you just sort of
sit these nice trimmed lettuce leaves
around now the exciting part serve take
your lettuce up spoon in your mins and
then a little touch of dressing
just a little
drizzle nice and that's the secret of
having good easy relaxed food is that
you just help yourself food that looks
and tastes a million bucks doesn't have
to be
complex this dish is as fun to cook as
it is to
[Music]
eat one of the keys to keeping it simple
is to prepare all the ingredients in
advance the more organized you are in
the kitchen the easier cooking becomes
here are three of my favorite quick
recipes that with a bit of advanced
preparation are so simple to
[Applause]
[Music]
make starting with my easy fragrant
fried
[Applause]
[Music]
rice first get preps chopped garlic
ginger and chili keeping the seeds for
extra
kick sliced spring onions
chop spring greens and trim a head of
broccoli then whisk two
eggs prep done stir fry
on add a good lug of oil to a hot
pan garlic ginger
chili next the spring greens and
broccoli add water to
steam then cooked rice this dish is
perfect for using leftover rice
make a well add the
eggs spring onions and a dash of fish
sauce scramble then
mix
[Applause]
season top with lime and spring
[Music]
onions my fragrant fried rice made
simple with Advanced prep and ready in 5
minutes
my next recipe it pays to get prepped
for is garlic and saffron
[Music]
mayonnaise first get your ingredients to
hand eggs should be out of the fridge
and at room
temperature soak saffron in warm
water saffron is the most expensive
spice in the world made from the dried
stigma of crocus flowers but even a
pinch gives a fantastic taste and a
wonderful color
color next separate three eggs put the
yolks into a mixing
bowl add djon mustard finely chopped
garlic the drained saffron and a squeeze
of lemon then
mix whisking constantly add oil slowly
it won't take
forever for perfect flavor use half
olive oil and half vegetable
oil when the mayonnaise comes together
season a smooth thick consistency means
it's
done top with
saffron Rich delicious and perfect with
everything from Seafood to sandwiches
and chips my second recipe garlic and
saffron mayonnaise easy to get right as
long as you've planned
ahead my final dish that's a stench to
cook with a little Advanced prep work is
muscles with celery and
[Music]
chili first prep the veg chopped spring
onions
shots a clove of garlic and chili to
taste then thinly sliced
celery add a bay leaf and Thyme veg
ready add oil to a pan and
[Music]
Fry season then add must Muses and
stir muscles one of my favorite
shellfish cheap healthy and
delicious cover and sting for a couple
of
minutes as the muscles open add verou an
aromatic 45
wine and 150 mil of dry white
[Music]
wine on a high heat reduce the liquid to
create a
source discard any muscles that are
still
shut
then finish with creme fresh and chop
[Music]
parsley minimal prep and cooked in less
than 10 minutes my muscles with celery
and chili impressive affordable and
super
Speedy make it simple in the kitchen by
prepping your ingredients in advance and
I promise you'll find these three
recipes a pleasure to make
[Music]
amazing
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment this is my
quick guide to kitchen
knives basically need three knives a
heavy duty chopping knife followed by a
small pairing knife which is brilliant
for prepping vegetables and then this
baby here a serrated edge knife for
carving and slicing basically that is
it before you buy a knife hold it in
your hand and make sure it feels right
for you
you the secret behind a great set of
knives is in the handle if you're
comfortable holding the handle you're
cutting it's going to be so much easier
the firmer the grip the better the
chopping the heavier the handle the more
control you've got over the blade with
these three knives you can't go
wrong coming up on my Ultimate Guide to
keeping it simple more cooking tricks of
the trade you cut that off the onion
will start to bleed and you'll start
crying rapidly All About Fish I could
feed you a different fish
365 days a year and an amazing poach
salmon turn the salmon into your hand
and just peel let skin
[Music]
on welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course this is my guide to keeping it
simple my next recipe is easy and a
pleasure to make if you're organized
with everything ready in
advance
miso poach salmon with Asian vegetables
organization is key in the kitchen take
a couple of minutes before you start and
set yourself up make sure you know where
everything is stock spatula pan Etc it
becomes less stressful but more
importantly the end results are
incredible first off get your pan on
whis and
stock start off with this amazing
fermented soybean puree into the p
three nice tablespoons gas on now get
your fish stock and whisk into the puree
be generous with the stock you want this
nice light broth
basically you can buy miso paste from
Big supermarkets and it works
brilliantly with
salmon poaching the salmon in the Miso
sty gives it a really nice sort of sweet
earthy creamy flavor it's incredible
bring up to the bow going to infuse the
bro broth and make it a little bit more
fragrant cafia Lime Leaf is very lemony
inside the Miso broth then Cho
chili Chili's
in and finally sliced
Ginger that's simmering beautifully now
we're going to poach the salmon poaching
means cooking in liquid but it's cooked
gently and the secret here is to keep
that Salmon skin on if we took the skin
off now the salmon can actually break up
whilst it's poaching skin side down just
going to slide that
in
under nice the minute that stock starts
boiling turn it down let it simmer take
a little Ladle and just every couple of
minutes pour over that makes sure the
top of the salmon is cooked evenly and
keeps it nice and
moist and poaching is one of the most
delicate ways of cooking so you have to
handle it with care whilst the Salmon's
poaching in the Miso broth start
preparing your vegetables I'm using
tender stem broccoli and packed
Choy I always like to cook the leaf and
the stem separately the leaf is like
sort of spinach and the stem is so much
thicker it's almost as thick as a stick
of celery so I like to get the stems
sliced just so I got that nice sort of
crismas place the leaves together nicely
roll them up nice and tight and then
slice them down
now my salmon already the flavor in that
broth has been
elevated now it tastes really fishy got
the heat the chili spiciness the ginger
and the cafe Lime Leaf take your fish
slice and place it very gently
underneath the salmon and push it down
fish slices are flexible for that reason
bend it lift it up just touch looking
for a springy firm texture just
sit that on top it will touch of the
broth over it it stops it from drying
out leave that to cool down for 2
minutes bring the stock back up to the
boil broccoli in back Choy stems in
Little
[Music]
Taste it's getting better and better and
better cook the broccoli and the Bro
stems for 1 minute and then add the tops
in
turn the salmon into your
hand and just peel all that skin off the
skin also helps to keep the salmon nice
and moist then gently flake the salmon
that's the secret behind poaching
everything just stays so moist wonderful
long shards of pink now just before we
serve we're going to add our mushrooms
these are in noi mushrooms you can buy
these in noi mushrooms in big
supermarkets and good grossers slice
them off I'm going to put half in and
the other half I'm going to serve with
the salmon toasted sesame seed oil put a
little drip in there just
rub and you're just lining almost like a
little coat of varnish start off with
your mushrooms and then my
salmon four nice
layers and then finally my
mushrooms top with the vegetables and
then finally a nice Ladle that beautiful
really Sumptuous Rich
stock
lovely and that is an amazing misu
poached salmon soup simplify your
cooking by getting organized and amazing
food will be coming out of your kitchen
every day and for great food you need
great
ingredients next up my shopping guide to
getting the finest
fish when I buy my fish I only want the
freshest and the best
and if anyone knows how to get the best
it's Roger Kent Bon he's been buying and
selling fish at the world famous
billions Gate Market in London for over
50 years I love fish I think it's the
greatest food of all time I sell
literally every variety there is I could
feed you a different fish
365 days a year this guy really knows
how to sniff out the good from the bad
all fish smell different the longer it's
around the more fish you it will smell
when it's lovely and
fresh it doesn't smell whenever you're
going to buy fish don't be frightened
get your nose right into it don't go
like that get it into it smell
it smells delightful it smells what I
call salmon and it's lovely baramundi
it's a lovely fish the way to tell good
fish is look at it closely it's shining
it's still got the Bloom on it his eyes
are bright as yours looking the girl
lovely and red put it in a bag for the
gentleman please people should always be
asking about their fish what kind of
fish is it where does it come from a
nice salmon 19 it's a bargain at 20
Roger right Salmon's brilliant value and
a great allrounder really healthy and
super delicious here's a quick look at
the different cuts and how to use
[Music]
them H salmon always impresses it's
fantastic stuffed and steamed either in
a fish Kettle or in the oven wrapped in
foil steaks are Great Value and
Brilliant baked a cider salmon is
perfect for poaching home curing or
baking in pastry the fillet is so
versatile easy fast to cook and great
for pan frying smoked salmon delicious
cooked or raw I love it with scrambled
[Music]
eggs broadly there's white fish and
there's oily fish they come under two
different sections here we have white
fish it's lovely it's c it's the best
cod in the world it comes from a place
called Peter head it's nice and white
the whiter the better one of the most
Oly fish you'll find mael there it is
lovely color with most fish the fresher
they are the harder they are if you're
not well and you're ill have a mael
sprats otherwise known as top hats here
we have flatfish and these are known as
place as you can see they've got spots
the redder they are the fresher they are
it really is a lovely fish to eat King
George couldn't have better for Fish
Fresh enough for royalty follow your
fish mongers advice and you'll never
ever have another dodgy DOA Soul
again next my tricks of the trade and
kitchen
[Music]
tips first how to chop an onion this is
the root that's absolutely crucial leave
that on there if you cut that off the
onion will start to bleed and you'll
start crying rapidly slice going forward
let the weight of the knife do the work
three fingers one in front two behind
and this part of the knuckle is going to
guide the knife fingers on top of the
onion point the knife towards the root
and try to get as close to the root as
possible nice long
stroke and then push the onion back
together push the knife halfway into the
onion slightly Tilt The Knife Down one
at the top
and then gripping the onion like a
tennis ball holding it together in
place with the weight of the blade to
cut through that onion to you get to the
base of the
root again turn it round up and down
motion and that's what we're left there
no waste just the root and
look there youve got a really nice
finely chopped onion so much great
cooking depends on starting with a high
enough heat if a recipe calls for a hot
pan put it on early so it gets smoking
hot and always remember to preheat your
oven at least 20 minutes before
cooking a clean cook is an efficient
cook my tip for a tidy cooking area is
to always have a waste bowl next to you
it saves you going back and forth to the
[Music]
bin never add salt to eggs before
cooking them because it ruins the
texture and dulls the color instead save
your seasoning to the very end
[Music]
the key to cooking meat is to make sure
it's at room temperature before you
begin cook straight from the fridge the
muscle fibers will be tight which
results in tough meat and always let it
rest afterwards so it relaxes becoming
tender and
[Music]
juicy Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and
100 recipes to steak your ion and you'll
literally be cooking yourself into a
better Chef many of these amazing
recipes are on my app please check out
the app store for details go on get
cooking